turning now to some big news for our cbs
family listen to this
i've decided
um i've decided to sign for one more
year on the show and that this will be
this will be my last year hosting the
late nation
yes yes yes that is our own james corden
revealing yesterday that he plans to
leave his hosting gig at the late late
show about a year from now we're going
to talk about this in just a moment but
first here's a look at gordon's
incredible run on the show so far
it has been more than seven years since
james corden first jumped into the
spotlight
as the host of cbs's own the late late
show i'm in the plane i'm with tom
[Music]
from skydiving with tom cruise to
harmonizing with adele
[Music]
to rap battling dame helen mirren and
reenacting samuel l jackson's film
career what's my name
corden has the special ability to create
moments that transcend television
clean it up harry the british comedian
was visibly emotional as he spoke about
stepping away there'll be so many tears
um
because this has been the hardest
decision i've ever had to make it really
has i've
i've never taken this job for granted
ever i think james corden's had a
fantastic run peter white is a tv editor
for deadline you've seen big stars go on
his show before they've perhaps gone on
some of the others and i think that's
because they know they're gonna have fun
stop and say hello
hello hello
not even sir paul mccartney could resist
cordon's famed carpool karaoke it's
become a huge hit along with the
crosswalk the musical segments
[Music]
as for what comes next gordon says he
doesn't know just yet but it's sure to
be a show-stopper here's to the next 12
months it is going to be a blast i
promise you that we'll be right back
with more of the late late everybody
the late late show celebrated its 1
000th episode with gordon hosting in
december in his announcement gordon said
hosting the show has changed his life
and ours too i feel like i miss him
already i was gonna say isn't it
touching though to see him get so choked
up i remember when he started seven
years ago and anna wintour was asked
who's the funniest person and she said
james corden i'd do google who was that
most of us in this country did not know
his name and now everybody knows his
name he's so beloved he's very sensitive
as you can see there and just one of the
nicest nicest guys i can't wait to see
what he does next yeah and i mean
carpool karaoke changed the game in so
many ways to have these big artists
jumping into a car and then you see
adele's expression when he actually they
realize he can a man can harmonize and
he can sing we've been honored to have
him as our lead in all these years
i hope who's ever on his bucket list for
carpool karaoke will do it you beyonce
after that due to five days
the dogs are still howling